hello fellow geeks in this video we are
going to take a look at the garmin
instinct esports edition smartwatch
it's a 299 us dollar or 459 singapore
dollar mid-level gps gaming smartwatch
built not only for adventure and sports
but for gamers as well
this esports edition of the instinct
series levels up the playing field with
its dedicated esports activity profile
and it comes with its own esports
software that allows you to broadcast
your biometrics directly to your gaming
streams through the garmin stream up app
it comes with a sleek black box with red
orange accents with a sketch style
design of the watch on the front
at the back it's not much information
other than the box contents so let's
open this up
in the box we get the watch itself
a small manual
and its proprietary charging cable with
a usb type a and one n it doesn't come
with its own charging plug but you can
connect the watch to a computer portable
charger or usb charging hub to charge
the watch the watch is also not
compatible with wireless charging so the
only way to charge it is to use the
cable that comes with it the watch has a
traditional circular shape but it
changes things up with its bold colours
following its packaging with its matte
black and red orange accents
it also has an aggressive look that will
appeal to gamers
this is a monochrome display with no
touchscreen capabilities and its display
size is a custom two window design at 23
by 23 millimeters with a display
resolution of 128 by 128 pixels
the bezel and case material of the watch
is made out of fiber reinforced polymer
and the lens material is made of
chemically strengthened glass
it's also good to note that the watch
along with the watches of the instinct
series are also built with the us
military standard 810 these watches are
tested for a range of environmental
conditions so it can perform in high
altitude
extreme cold
or heat
and can withstand repeated shocks
turbulence and sharp impacts it is also
resistant to rain and dust corrosion the
garmin instinct is also water resistant
up to 100 meters so it's great if you do
a lot of water sports and activities
wearing the watch the watch fits
comfortably on the wrist moving my wrist
around does not interfere with the
buttons and it feels light for its
weight the size of the bezel is big
enough and the display is sharp moving
on to the physical buttons on the watch
on the bezels we have five buttons in
total
pressing the control light button to
activate the backlight and holding it
will bring you to the controls menu
pressing the menu up button will scroll
outwards through the widget loop and
menus and holding it will view the main
menu pressing the abc down button will
also scroll downwards through the widget
loop and menus
and holding it will view the altimeter
barometer and compass screen
pressing the gps button will view the
activity list
and start or stop an activity it also
chooses an option in the menu and
holding it will view the gps coordinates
and save your location last but not
least we have the back set button which
will return you to the previous screen
and holding it will view the clock menu
regarding sensors we have an
accelerometer for counting steps wrist
heart rate monitor we also get a
gyroscope for motion data an electronic
compass
and barometric automated sensor you also
get gps glowness and galileo satellite
positioning for tracking regarding
battery life by default it can last up
to 14 days and more with normal casual
use and up to 16 hours if you activate
gps mode esports mode will get you up to
80 hours and ultra track mode up to 40
hours
in my test i had everything on default
with esports mode activated every now
and then
it lasted me about 12 days which is
pretty decent for smartwatch at this
price let's take a look at our main
screen
now a good thing to note is that the
instinct does not have other watch faces
you can download and transfer over from
the app however you are able to
customize the watch face there are 12
presets to choose from let's go with
this watch face and you're able to
customize the watch face to suit your
needs
i like these settings so we can leave it
as that
and we'll go ahead and confirm the
setting
anyway the presets and customization on
the watch itself is good enough and has
plenty of styles to choose from on the
main watch face you can cycle through
some widgets already in place you have a
pedometer
a heart rate monitor
hours rested a record of our steps and
calories burnt throughout the day a
notifications panel and a calendar
synced to our phone and the current
weather
holding the abc button will bring us to
the widget loop where we can view more
widgets we can view the compass
altimeter
and barometer
going to the control menu we have a few
options here we can power off the device
control the backlight
a do not disturb mode
a lock mode
it can also broadcast your heart rate
add alternate time zones
[Music]
we also have some basic music controls
where you can play pause
play the next or previous track and even
control the volume
there's also a fire my phone function
and audio chime plays from the phone
which gives you a general direction of
where the phone is located and is useful
when you've misplaced your phone
somewhere else
moving on to the clock menu here we can
set alarms a timer stopwatch
we can also set the time with a gps and
set up alerts like sunrise sunset and
stormy weather
calls and notifications are also in the
app calling will prompt the watch to
vibrate and a notification will pop up
you can either answer or decline the
call
however there is no microphone on the
watch so this is a good option if you're
on your wireless earphones while your
phone is in your pocket notifications
can be fully read however due to the
subdial layout some of the letters do
get cropped which can be annoying for
some
now let's set this watch to esports mode
going to esports mode we can view some
data
the current time
heart rate a timer of how long we've
been gaming
and our current stress level on the next
page we can view the maximum and average
heart rate and maximum stress level we
mentioned the garmin stream up app at
the start of the video and we'll show
you how you can overlay it on a
broadcaster software so you can view
your biometrics while streaming an
intense game session the garmin stream
up software is a pretty basic one
you are able to set three values heart
rate stress and body battery you can
also choose some preset orientations
and styles and of course change the
color down here we have some overlays
that can be activated if the value has
hit a certain threshold
so if my heart rate goes up to 110 this
animated overlay will play
we also have an animated frame border
that can be used
for this video we will go with a basic
setup so let's take a look at how it
looks like while playing overwatch as
you can see the stream up app works in
real time i did not experience any
connection problems while playing games
and this is a great way to showcase your
biometrics and is great for intense
action and horror games
next up a quick tour of the garmin
connect app and its features
going to the garmin connect app you can
view a graphic of our current heart rate
next is the body battery details this is
a very interesting detail that i have
not seen on other smart watches this
measures the amount of energy reserves
you have throughout the day with this
panel it recommends how active and how
much rest you should be having and just
below that is a record summary from
yesterday and the last 7 days what's
great about the app is that you can view
challenges and earn badges it's sort of
like a reward system where you can
self-improve and stay active if you have
friends or family members who have
gaming watches as well you can
participate in challenges and compete
with one another next is the calendar
where you can view some details about
the activities and stats throughout the
month
and next is the newsfeed panel where you
can view the activities of your friends
and their achievements
overall the gummy connect app its user
interface
and the ease of access to the app is
very polished and well designed all the
information that is needed is all in
there the overall performance and design
of the watch makes it easy to use for
sports and active tracking
and it's also great for gamers who like
to take their games and streams to the
next level with the capability of adding
the heart rate and stress level overlays
to their gameplay the ui on the watch
does take some time to get used to
because it uses physical buttons instead
of a touch screen one if you're looking
for a smartwatch that is suited for
those involved in both fitness and
gaming it sure does offer a lot of
features for its price
thank you for watching this video if you
haven't already consider subscribing to
our channel and give us a like and don't
forget to smash that bell icon so you
can stay updated to our latest videos
until then this is zaki signing off
adios which i chose
[Music]